fin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti très loin la plus aucune
pudeur c'est à dire sa part nous qui
avons connu des premières années ça a
beaucoup changé
alors les chéris c'est à dire vous allez
donc piocher ici c'est pas une boule
jaune c'est une vérité une boule noire
ces stages ça va quand même une bonne
chose sera de vérité et je vois à dire à
l'autre ces trois plus gros défaut pas
professionnel ça on s'en est rendu
compte depuis le début du deuxième
arrogant c'est assez évident et
troisième coureur vénale non oui
pourquoi il est là où bénévoles - simon
prétentieux égoïste à n'importe quoi
parce que ça et me tiens je vais donner
mon iphone en plus une action
la somme est de dos avec une perruque on
lance la musique des feux de l'amour
c'est de retourner les feux de l'amour
l'autre pose sa main sur l'épaule de son
binôme ai dit je te pardonne richard
vers vous embrasser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était pardonne rien
j'ai mal joué mais je te pardonne aux
six mois maintenant
on la refait mais dans l'autre sens
d'une fête richard j'ai beaucoup milité
dans mon ranch du wyoming et sache je te
pardonne un chat
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
senard
merci match au point ce soir les gones
face non c'est bon merci
à
[Musique]